or the vice president we understand
might not report until tomorrow
and maricopa which is the county where
phoenix is
we know is likely to report at least
some of their outstanding ballots but
not
until later tonight so the story of
arizona is one where joe biden is going
to win but it's going to take us
time and patience as we go through uh
the counting you might see
we would expect to see and and we will
see a tightening of that margin
throughout the day but more favorable
data will be coming in this evening and
even into tomorrow um so just be
be conscious of that and and become as
you see that throughout the day
so let's talk about two other states
that are uh
still out there and still in play um one
that is getting a lot of attention and
that we are also
obviously very focused on that would be
georgia
this race as we said the last time we
spoke is a
true toss-up and uh we are seeing
uh this as of this morning and i know
the secretary of state just
had a press conference um our uh we are
seeing us
continuing to cut into the advantage
that donald trump has
he is leading by about 18 000 votes but
there are a significant number of
outstanding ballots that the secretary
of state just spoke to
that we expect to be coming in
throughout the day some counties like
fulton county or atlanta is counted
through the night
um but we have a very good sense of
where
the outstanding uh ballots are um mostly
coming from
more democratic leaning areas as well as
from
male and voters places where the vice
president has
had significant support across the
country
so we believe that georgia while
continuing to be
a toss-up while continuing to be
something that is going to be very very
close
at this stage leans to the vice
president
and so keep an eye on georgia throughout
the day as we are but i think
we're heading on our path to close that
18 000
uh vote margin and uh potentially
overtake it
north carolina um the final state to
speak to today
this race continues to be very tight no
real changes in terms of updated data
but we're staying on top of what's
coming in making sure that we have a
very good sense of that and we'll
provide
updates as we see throughout the day
so hopefully that gives you a sense of
how we're approaching and thinking about
the states
we are grateful to everyone who is doing
the hard hard work of counting votes in
these states
counting votes and counting every vote
is a fundamental tenet of our democracy
and we are so grateful for the hard work
that's being done
as we said with people counting
overnight and
day after day um keep at it but doing a
great job and we're grateful that work
um this is happening you know this is
what's happening right now this is
how we are looking at the morning i
think the story of today
is going to be a very positive story for
the vice president but also one
where folks are going to need to stay
patient and stay calm
the counting is happening it's going to
take time we need to allow it to get
done and done well
and we're very confident whatever
happens uh with the counting and the
timing we will come out ahead we are
absolutely confident
that joe biden will be the next
president of the united states uh and we
are equally confident
that we're going to be able to watch uh
the counting throughout the day and into
tomorrow
to finalize these last states that are
going to put us over the top to 217.
so with that update i'm now going to
hand this uh presentation over to bob
bauer to talk a little bit more
about how we are looking at uh donald
trump's efforts in these
final hours uh and the strategy that
we're putting forth
um on our behalf so bob over to you
thank you jen
i just wanted to uh put into the right
sort of frame and perspective what you
are hearing from some of the states
about trump claims and
trump lawsuits uh and i think
they're connected the lawsuits uh are
meritless
they're intended to give the trump
campaign the opportunity to argue that
the vote count should stop it is not
going to stop
and i'll walk through uh some of the
silliness behind these claims
momentarily but i want to emphasize that
for their purposes these lawsuits
don't have to have merit that's not the
purpose is not to bring
bona fide claims before the courts is to
create an opportunity for them to
message falsely
about what's taking place in the
electoral process and to go to jen's
point it's really quite remarkable these
election officials are working
overnight trying to get the count out
and trying to get it right
and the trump campaign is continually
alleging
irregularity failures of the system and
fraud without any basis
this is part of a broader misinformation
campaign
that involves some political theory
theater you may have heard about
some loud noises being made by trump
supporters at the polling places
uh the shouts of stop the vote count and
the like well
be aware that wherever this is happening
and is happening
inappropriately at close proximity to
the polling place
uh law enforcement and election
officials are clearing the place as
quickly of this kind of behavior
and ensuring that the vote count can
continue but all of this is intended to
create a large cloud
that it is the hope of the trump
campaign that nobody can see through
but it is not a very thick cloud it's
not hard to see what they're doing
we see through it so will the courts and
so do election officials
now let me begin let me just close by
saying a little bit so that you have
some grounding in
what these lawsuits seem to be about
let's take two
three examples georgia michigan and
pennsylvania so let's take georgia in
chatham county
uh the trump campaign showed up to
allege that 53
late arriving ballots were mixed with
ballots received on time
what was the evidence of that well a
trump observer expressed some suspicion
about something that may have happened
uh when that uh observer left the room
that was it that was the sole purpose of
it
uh the sole basis of it is sort of an
expression of suspicion
so the trump campaign requested that
georgia counties
separate any and all late arriving
ballots
well that's interesting because that's
what election officials are already
doing
because that's what the law requires so
you have a suspicion that is expressed
as the basis for a lawsuit demanding
that election officials do
what election officials are already
doing because the law requires it i
think
it's kind of comic but that's what's
involved
another example comes from michigan in
michigan uh the trump campaign
a file suit alleging that republican
inspectors should have been afforded the
opportunity to witness
the collection of ballots from drop
boxes and they asked for the counting
to be halted well the collection from
the drop boxes was conducted by trained
election officials precisely as provided
by law
and the claim is completely meritless
it's a messaging exercise it has no
other purpose
than to confuse the public about what's
taking place and to support
their baseless claims of irregularity
final example from pennsylvania
they continue to file suits in this case
in many cases they're litigating over
issues
they've already litigated so they're
kind of running out of ideas and they're
recycling
them and in other instances they're
filing over utterly
immaterial matters like where they may
be permitted to stand
and observe while the counting takes
place
as another example they've intervened in
a pending supreme court case in
involving pennsylvania but their lawyers
are already there representing the
republican party
so they're intervening one more time
with the same legal team to duplicate
a filing that's already taken place to
give people the impression
that something important is happening in
the united states supreme court
but in fact it's not uh it's the same
old case with the same parties
lined up arguing the same issues nothing
has changed
so let me just close by saying this
strategy
of disrupting the vote count as you can
tell by the efforts of election
officials to continue to count
is doomed to fail but in the background
the noise is
fraud irregularity and the like and the
lawsuits
and the disruptive behavior are all
for that purpose of trying to get the
vote counted try to confuse the public
about what's taking place
and we'll make sure the public is clear
about what's taking place
and election officials operating under
the law will make sure that the vote
count
continues thank you
thanks bob and thanks everyone we're
happy to take some questions
uh we're going to hannah trudeau first
hannah if you want to meet yourself
hi guys can you hear me yep yes thank
you okay thanks a lot
um yeah thanks for doing this i i'm
wondering jen if you can speak a little
bit
more in depth about why you feel um as
certain as you do about
about arizona and also curious if you've
spoken or had any contact with the trump
campaign today
hey hannah yeah so um arizona we
we felt good about all along it wouldn't
be a presentation if i didn't say that
i'm
bullish on arizona um you know look we
um
really understand um that uh
this is a race that we've been ahead we
expected it all along to be
close and as we look at the data that's
outstanding
we see a number of democratic counties
that are yet to report
maricopa we you know as i said today
we do expect the margin to be closing we
knew that and we
had seen that even coming into um
election
a night after we started to see the
results so this is the trajectory
that we have been headed we will win by
tens of thousands of votes
but that margin will close and as i said
um you know
uh arizona and nevada i think there'll
be
some bounce throughout the day um and
the margin will tighten but that's what
we've been expecting all along
um and that you know the only challenge
with arizona is um the data
now if we understand it as we currently
uh do in terms of timing it could be
tonight and
as well as pima coming in tomorrow um
and more of maricopa tomorrow as well so
it might take a little bit longer to get
there
um we have not had contact throughout
the day and we're just plugging along
with
our focus on making sure that the votes
are counted uh
and that we're uh pushing forward here
uh whip alex jaffe next hi guys thanks
for
holding this call um jen i wanted to
check in since you are expressing
confidence that the ultimate result of
the election you guys have
started ramping up transition planning
and if you can speak about
sort of what that looks like imminently
what you're planning to announce in the
coming days
after the the race is called if it is
called in your favor
so the good thing is that i'm the
campaign manager and so what i'm focused
on
is getting these final votes done um you
know we're we're very focused on making
sure the accounting goes on
um you know the vice president uh is
continuing to do the things that
um you know he's been doing every step
of the way not losing sight of the fact
that kovid
uh cases are rising day after day in
this country as well and making sure
that he's briefing on that
um so we're going to just continue to
focus on on the campaign and and
closing out these final states
uh we have chris smith next
hey good morning thanks for talking uh
one for
each of you jen given where the counts
are
is there a state you think is going to
come in
first and get you over 270 and
bob we haven't seen it well
have you seen any evidence of the
attorney general
bill barr getting involved in
any of this maneuvering on
trump's side and do you expect to see it
so um just to that first question um to
be honest i
i don't know um you know i think that um
we are doing our best like everyone else
is to get a sense of timing
um you know and and monitoring that you
know we will
see more moving in a number of places
this morning
um certainly we know from an arizona
standpoint the current timing
puts us into tomorrow um you know
pennsylvania has a large volume
of uh ballots to still go through um so
that will take some time so
at this stage it's not clear um you know
when that final count will come in the
timing um and we're just going to stay
close
uh on all of them
as for uh the attorney general no we
have not seen uh any indication
of any kind of unusual or concerning
activity there
there'd be no basis for the department
of justice to become involved
the conduct of these elections uh is the
responsibility of the states and as we
can all see
they're perfectly capable of conducting
these counts
uh and also of enforcing order and
indeed
that is what they are that's what
they're charged with doing so this is a
state matter
not a matter for the department of
justice and we see no reason to believe
that
that fundamental allocation of
responsibility
is one that the attorney general is
planning to challenge in any way
uh for our last question we have asthma
khalid hi there uh thank you guys so
much uh can you hear me okay
yep okay great um two quick questions
um one is what is your sense of the your
sort of best sense of the remaining vote
in philly and then also i
know there was an iteration of this kind
of ass but amongst the
remaining states do you have any sense
if you could sort of
rank them for me in terms of your level
of optimism if you feel
just where you think they are if we
could rank uh north carolina georgia
arizona nevada pennsylvania
so um you know pennsylvania and philly
in particular i know there's a lot of
uncertainty about the exact numbers
there and i know there's a few different
um narratives kind of swirling online um
you know there are hundreds of thousands
of ballots outstanding you know we think
it's probably
um in the 500 to 700 000 plus across the
whole state
um what i can tell you is that what we
have seen
um in places like milwaukee and detroit
and pittsburgh
um and and we also expect in philly is
is
very high turnout um and so uh you know
we think that there is uh
still significant outstanding ballot in
philly but of course across the entire
state and uh as folks know that the vice
president has been carrying
very very high margins uh with vote by
mail uh in particular
and from um uh communities like these
and so
uh we expect that we will have a really
strong showing today as accounting
is underway um you know in terms of
um the states and and optimism
you know look i feel very very good
about all the states i think north
carolina is a little bit tighter a
little bit tougher
um you know uh we are looking for that
moment
in pennsylvania and georgia today where
we see that ticker overtake
donald trump we think it's gonna happen
um but i'm confident in all
four uh bullish uh on on the all four of
those states i'm gonna expand
my statement on bullishness uh outside
of arizona
um but we're very optimistic and um you
know
we don't we don't really care which
state takes us over the top we just want
to keep
uh going and make sure the counts get
done and as i said earlier
um you know the accounting is underway
we know that it's going to take a little
bit of time
and we support that and we're just going
to stay calm
and uh and be patient um and at the end
of the day we'll we'll be situated well
regardless of uh what those early states
uh
are with the remains
of this state i care deeply about both
the rule of law and voter integrity
like the rest of nevadans and americans
and we warned for the last few weeks
that we could end up in a situation
where nevada
decides the fate of the presidency
we warned that the democrats changed
this election system they gave us
mail-in
ballots and despite the fact
that there are examples of thousands of
ballots
being mailed across this valley in trash
cans in apartment buildings
people getting as many as 18 ballots to
their homes
we knew these these roles were unclean
and we were told that signatures
would save us from all fraud but to date
we still have not been able to observe
these signatures or or meaningfully
challenge
a single male invalid out of hundreds of
thousands of castes
we firmly believe that there are many
voters
in this group of mail-in people that are
not
proper voters in the last many days
we have received reports of many
irregularities
across the valley we we believe that
there are dead voters
that have been counted we are also
confident that there are thousands
of people whose votes have been counted
that have moved out of clark county
in the during the pandemic
today we have a voter
jill stokey who was denied access
to vote she showed up to vote
and she was told someone had already
cast